president Trump's historic summit with
North Korean leader Kim jong-un is
starting to take shape they will meet in
Singapore on June 12 one month from
tomorrow White House officials say the
island nation has relations with the US
and North Korea and can ensure the
safety of both leaders the president
celebrated the progress with North Korea
last night in Indiana he told an adoring
crowd his upcoming meeting will be in
his words a very big success Paula Reed
is at the White House with more on this
story Paula good morning good morning
the president has several public events
here at the White House today and when
we have gotten some new details about
this upcoming summit what we don't know
is whether the President and Kim jong-un
will spend any private one-on-one time
during that meeting but while White
House officials work out the specific
details the president is celebrating
America is being respected again
speaking at a rally in Elkhart Indiana
last night
a triumphant president Trump hailed the
release of three American prisoners from
North Korea we welcome them back home
the proper way and recognize the
regime's leader Kim Jong did a great
service to himself to his country by
doing this shortly after they arrived on
US soil the men were whisked away to
Walter Reed Hospital a US official tells
CBS News that medical professionals did
not identify any significant medical or
psychiatric concerns during their
journey and it's expected that the men
will only be at Walter Reed a short time
they're going through a period of
transition they're decompressing Brian
hook a senior policy adviser at the
State Department who accompanied
Secretary Pompeo to Pyongyang described
their recovery process they're trying to
return to a normal life that's going to
take time and right now we're just
taking it one day at a time he
downplayed concerns about overwhelming
the men with such a public arrival it
was very exciting to see the President
of the United States meet them on the
aircraft and walk with them just hours
after greeting the freed prisoners
President Trump tweeted that his
historic summit with Kim jong-un will
take place in Singh
poor on June 12th I'll be meeting with
kim jonghwan to pursue a future of peace
and security for the world for the whole
world the White House says the
president's goal at this summit is
complete irreversible and verifiable
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
the white house warns that any
provocative action by North Korea over
the next month could scuttle this
much-anticipated
summit Nora all right Paula thank you so
much